ragazzi lo sentite sfavore qui questo
dovrei particolare e l'odore del quality
content e sta arrivando
e allora let's go baby band a tutti i
ragazzi minuti questo video sono parigi
oggi siamo su come si chiama fashion
style fashion siamo su fashion star moda
creativa che è un niente si rifiuta di
partire crasha direttamente il gioco ma
come biasimarlo come in realtà questo
gioco che non sta partendo
ef amici giocare a sto fashion star moda
creativa con scaricato sono
contentissima mente non perdere fashion
star moda creativa uno dei giochi più
scaricati sull'app store e scopriremo
subito il perché quanti anni hai
23 e sto giocando a questa roba qui dove
ho 23 anni ma pensa che danno l'opzione
anche sarebbe vedere quanto è il massimo
che poi mette dentro per quella tra due
o più di 81 sono arrivati a 81 più di 81
impossibile quindi mettiamo 81 più pro
fino a 80 anni ci si poteva giocare
credo che anche armani abbia iniziato a
giocare a queste cose poi approfondito
armadi più più avanti non ho niente da
vestire o fuori ma che la fame nel mondo
non c'è niente allestire povera crista
andiamo avanti
che bella andiamo avanti sì faccio io
che sono tutti forti con le forbici
ecco adesso c'è un improvvisa voglia di
prendere il coltello della cucina
affettare i miei boxer a vedere cosa
succede dopo lo faccio
mammamia ferragni ferragni dell'ipa per
la scuola chiara che a chiara castria
fedez via foresta qashqai live parliamo
di business c'è la scritta summer
addirittura mito sono la media molto 100
euro sta magliano top story taglio non
so che come chiamarlo posso fare a posto
scattare stesso tavole pace dall'altro
fotocamera certo certo
cosa faccio
[Musica]
ecco che cosa dovrei trascinare ma no ma
no macché business ma che visti fermi
fermi devo fare allora allora cambiamo
no vabbè ma sto male ma è bellissimo e
bellissimo come non l'ho scoperto questo
aggiungo prima
no no fermi zitti zitti che bellissimo e
bellissimo e gioco della vita adesso ho
capito perché è scaricato tantissimo
meglio di così cosa possiamo ma guarda
meraviglia tagliava wow this is so
incredi ma pure dietro dietro perché
riguarda il 17 va bene facciamo a venire
dietro abbiamo lasciato salme vabbè
comunque questo questa mamma mia
non me ne frega niente delle altre
applicazioni di questa è l'applicazione
della vita zitti 2
non so cosa sia quella la prima sicuro e
più commestibile di quello che cucino io
però eccola la gnocca
mammamia domani domani a fa pure le
views oppure click day tato con la mia
maglietta come domani una mamma mia che
mette che design marmo e fantastico
benissimo addirittura 123 un influencer
2 di sly è uno ed avverrà anni e l'altra
di armani treni slide questo dolce
gabbana sono dolce se n'è accorto che
banale ancora viva ecco gabbana per post
post porta su youtube by così cliomakeup
cosa da domani basta gameplay facciamo
solo cose creative va bene
poi c'è il mio camerino dove posso
indossare giustamente le cose bellissima
così guarda va in discoteca così che è
fantastico va bene direi di passare alla
gonna le gonne a queste donne e ragazzi
passiamo allo step successivo che
sicuramente sarà molto importante
la pro vasto posso fare i tempi sono
posti honsell ti va bene
scattati tre foto va bene una così
aspetto cambia pausa via
eccola lì una grande mamma mia che like
che farai su instagram domani mettono a
fuoco si distaccherà questa metodologia
vabbè ai filtri filtri telerama doppia
fighissimo vabbè andiamo avanti ragazzi
veramente fantasy ii liz meeker ecco che
ci siamo sono sodio invece una tesi da
raggiungere la foto dei tuoi album si
aggiunge ha pure questo grazie questo
oro ed a quanti lai che influencer ne
vado meglio sinistra granché se ne
tenuta quanti laico preso io
una gara di nike e una gara di wright
stabletrac no ha vinto quella badava che
schifo vuoi mettere a dainelli ma
maledetta sarine viola ma doppie primo
laura la mia madre ci somiglia pura mia
madre
vuoi migliorare paga 11 euro uguale seta
11 euro probabilmente di vento come la
ferragni due imprenditore life show di
next proviamo a fare il pezzo di sopra
solo le ferite sono bravo a fare quello
ne abbiamo parlato con positivi ecco il
pigiama prendiamo il pedale
ritagliamo il pigiama vediamo cosa
riusciamo a prendere allora ragazzi dopo
ore di attente ricerche per un design
valido per la mia nuova collezione
riuscito a trovare l'elemento penso
portato che riusciamo a prendere io
let's go my boys detto di no se sono un
pezzo benissimo venisse a saperlo prima
mamma mia ora molto easy molto easy
funzionale
direi che ci siamo voglio vederti cara
la mia come ti chiami next e poi
vedersela dopo di vederti indossare
questa meraviglia come non ho mai
giocato a questa roba come come una
serie c devo fare bellissime bel ali che
lo sfoggia complimenti l'ho chiamata
rosaria la maglia rosaria per il filing
this was so cool
wow wow esattamente ciò di cui la piazza
cosa non sto facendo la mia essere uno
youtuber vi giuro su dio non è mai stato
così divertente
farei anche quando giocavo ai tifosi
motori tris mi divertivo così tante
bellissime e il gioco è nel 2018 le
macchine voleranno ma che macchine
volanti questa tecnologia
di cosa stiamo parlando vai avanti posta
guardali ho scalato la classifica
ho superato angelina presa come si
vestiva angelina non voglio saperlo la
che è roba che che scherza welfare anche
cosa voglia dire prove c'è ancora
un'ultima roba che se mi permette se me
lo permettete voglio fare allora c'è un
altro soggetto che vorrei eccolo qua e
là era esattamente ciò di cui avevo
bisogno
perfetto perfetto così tutti
pregiudicati
questo è veramente il capolavoro dei
capolavori che lo dico allora il
soggetto in questione
so che state pensando tutti a pietro lo
so ma non è quello tensione
non so se voi siete pronti ma io lo sono
signori and next in causa nei c
best buy
[Musica]
l'ex viola e boys del sic ma allora cosa
quello che volevo
non so se è esattamente ciò che volete
sarebbe bellissimo mettere piedi di mare
cupi valgono per gli archivi
ti prego però devo farla questa cosa di
sul pil ma non lo faccia non lo faccio
perché sono una persona a modo però
l'avrei fatto per volere degli dei prof
allora marco poi ci devi rendere
giustizia ma penso che giustizia sia
fatta da buy
penso sia
c'è qualcosa c'è un po di rimasti un po
soprano scoperto ma chi se ne frega
va bene fammi vedere che cosa eccolo è
meraviglioso e la guardano come si
atteggia fantastici c'era c'era bisogno
di dirvi questo nella mia vita minuto il
nostro gioco contro uno guardali limite
se non è una cosa che c'è scritto il mio
guardaroba sembra migliore di dieci
volte rispetto a prima
va bene va bene post la maglietta marco
marino mi ha fatto scalare ben tre posti
in classifica siamo ben di 775 like
quasi il triplo set di live dove ragazzi
io direi che possono chiudere qui la mia
carriera mi aspetto al se non smettono
di fare video tra qualche anno è
iniziato alle armi nelle trine e normale
passate crudamente di otto qualcosa di
legato 23 magliette della collezione
brosio che secondo me un grande sacco
rubato io spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto e manderò la fota marco lo
davano chiusa mi risponde però anzi lo
faccio mi lasciano quasi ragazzi è
piaciuto è certamente mi piace anche
aiutarci a gomito
mettete in infusione bene però manda
tutto spiega mi sto guardando però se
fossi semino se io non ho questo vestito
da 381 velocità di che il macello
[Musica]